hello everybody welcome to the ninth
part of my SEO tutorial in this tutorial
we're actually going to be talking about
Google Analytics which you could really
use for things other than SEO the
purpose of google analytics in my
opinion is just website betterment so
that all you know also help your SEO but
really this is just more along the lines
of just making your website as good as
it can be and getting a lot of
information on your website that you
otherwise probably would not have so to
get there what you don't wanna do is go
to google.com / analytics and once
you're there you'll either want to sign
in to your account or you'll create an
account if you don't have an account
create one so once you've signed in if
you don't already have Google Analytics
this is what it look like I'm just using
an account that doesn't have any google
analytics on it and you'll obviously
want to sign up surprising and depending
on when you're watching this video
you'll you can either do this classic
analytics or the beta version of it go
ahead and do the beta if if you're
watching this now otherwise it's public
you know if you're watching this later
and they don't have these two options
probably won't have the choice but
anyway we want to do now is you create
an account name you'll add your website
you'll put in the website's URL and here
honestly forget like I was telling you
before with the SEO and stuff HTTP colon
slash slash centex com is different than
HTTP colon slash slash ww send XCOM but
as long as you have that tracker on
there at least the last time I look
there it you'll get no different stats
because you're actually putting a
tracker on the website natural code
behind the website so because of that
it's all being right into the same
website so whatever your actual website
is that that's what you want to put in
there and I almost think I think if you
put at least for me nevermind I can't
remember but later on you might want you
might have to change it if the in-page
analytics aren't working
but I'll bring that up again once we get
there you can pick your industry choose
all this stuff and then you hit get
tracking ID now I've already done all of
this I'm not going to do it but you'll
want to do that pause the video while
you do it once you have the tracking ID
usually you put it within like the
header or the footer file I think most
people probably put it in the footer if
you have WordPress most of the stuff has
like a space like a place in the
settings where you can put it in there a
lot of templates if you have like an
HTML CSS template you can put in there
and like I said if you have like a
regular website that you've made
yourself completely put it in the header
of the footer so it follows to every
single page so you can gather statistics
on all the pages so now I'm going to
cancel out of that and I'm actually
going to go back to my google analytics
account so we can start going through
some stuff so Google Analytics is just
massive there's no way i could really
cover everything in a new tutorial here
and it really just depends on what
you're interested in but i will just
show you guys a few things one of the
cooler things that i really like from
this website is the real-time view and
you can see you know what are people
doing right now on your website you can
see our page views per minute per second
if you had like a really active website
you can see you know where are you
getting your referrals from if you have
any are they direct and then you've got
social traffic's like Twitter Facebook
top keywords so any organic views you
would get the key words if there if
there are any then you you know here
you've got you know what are actually
people looking at so a couple people are
looking at my blackberry sentiment
analysis graft one person's on the
homepage and then someone else is
viewing the political sentiment analysis
stuff so you can kind of get a gauge for
like what are people actually doing
right now on my website so obviously
that's really fun another thing that you
can do as far as engagement is concerned
is you can come down to let me pull this
up a little bit and the content tab so
you click that to open it up and you can
click on in page analytics and you can
see on this what people actually do on
your website you can see where people
are clicking where they aren't clicking
now we'll just say
the time span that I'm viewing this is
May first to July thirty-first but the
actual date today is September 27th so
this is kind of older stuff and I have
kind of moved this some of this stuff
around so that's why there's like no
clicks here it sets a new button but
then when you pull it down some of these
have been there before and I can find
out you know on the hover button how
many people click what stuff and it can
kind of give you an idea of you know the
varying importance like you might think
you've got something on your website
that's like super cool and important you
might think everyone cares about it but
they really don't and it's just really
beneficial to you to find out what kind
of content you want to really have on
the front you know front page or the nav
bar and you can move that away so on
also along those lines you can also go
to the content tab just click on
overview and you can see basically you
know what's the most popular page
probably will be your homepage like it
is here but then you start finding out
like what kind of content are people
actually interested in viewing and then
from there you can click on that figure
out how much time are people spending on
that page how many people are leaving
the web page or the website from that
page and so on and if they are you can
kind of try to start figuring out ways
to keep people and retain them on your
website and then obviously the
demographics that can be pretty useful
especially like language you know what
language are the people that are viewing
your website for me most the vast
majority is English from the United
States then English Great Britain
English and then you've got you know
some other like Netherlands and Spanish
and France and all this stuff but
clearly it's not a huge priority for me
to you know have varying languages and
also just kind of like the responsive
argument that I made before as time goes
on it's probably less and less important
that you have like multi-language sites
just simply because like if you've ever
visited one recently in like chrome for
example that's not your language it will
offer to translate the page for you and
actually that pic that translation is
pretty darn good at least in my
experience so as time goes on it
probably won't even matter you know the
other thing that's
pretty useful is to you know click you
can click on mobile and overview even
though is going to give you more than
just mobile but now it tells you how
many people are viewing on what kind of
device so desktop mobile or tablet so I
can kind of tell you how important is it
to you to make your website very
responsive or isn't is it not important
at all so that's that so extreme basics
when it comes to the Google Analytics
also you know this is just kind of like
your dashboard so you can kind of view
your stats over like a longer time frame
and then four of these like say like now
really direct visits isn't really
important anymore because with this new
beta they have this thing here where you
can see like all visits and you can just
click down here and so that you can say
direct traffic right and you can remove
this say apply and now all it shows you
is your direct traffic so no longer is
this isn't as important as it used to be
now I had that there because I kind of
feel like direct traffic is a it's a
really good indication of how many
people are actually enjoying your
website enough to tell like revisit your
website right so that's why I read want
to direct traffic but anyway now with
this new beta and stuff and I believe in
the future it will probably always be
like this it's not really as necessary
so I can remove this but if you wanted
to change it maybe you can just hit edit
and then in here you can kind of choose
you know what kind of stuff you want you
want a timeline you want to just be like
a metric like a number you want a geomap
in like start plotting where people are
you want a pie chart so on you can say
you graph this metric and you can
compare it with another metric so one
comparison i have here is visits versus
unique visitors you can see that it's
actually a different number right the
number of total visits on July thirtieth
was 699 the amount of those that were
unique though were 6 42 so it kind of
does matter that as well so I just
always plot them on the same thing but
anyway we can delete this yes and then
if you want to add a widget you'd only
have like up to 12 widgets I think so so
anyway to add a widget kind of the same
thing you were just looking at you give
it a title specify what you want I mean
you can do all kinds of stuff like all
of these can be something that you
have something on so just depending on
what you care most about as far as your
website is concerned you can put that
right up here but then you know by the
time like you can come over here and
pretty much get to all of that stuff you
just have the dashboard for kind of like
a shortcut to figuring out you know your
your stats the other thing that's pretty
cool that you can do is you can set up
goals and and it can help you figure out
where you're going wrong maybe so like
if you have like a shopping site you can
set up various goals and you set up like
kind of like a funnel that leads to that
goal and you can kind of figure out
where along that funnel is is this
failing and you can kind of change your
website around that I mean Google
Analytics there's just so much you can
do with it and really the best thing you
can probably do is just come in here and
like go tab by tab by tab just like
looking at everything they have to offer
so it's just there's so much the best
thing you can do is just kind of just go
through it so anyway that's all I'm
really gonna say on Google Analytics
beside you know just get it and musics
it's so helpful for your website so that
will conclude part 9 of my SEO tutorial
and really just Google Analytics
tutorial hopefully that's use useful to
you guys hopefully do use Google
Analytics I just love it so anyway as
always thanks for watching thanks for
your support of subscriptions and until
next time